seth in westchester what's up seth
hey guys uh
big fan of the show
i wanted to know if troy thinks that the
moon landing never happened or if we've
never been to the moon period that's a
great question troy if you had to uh
guess
would you say
the first moon landing was fake and then
we got to the moon later or would you
say
none of the moon landings were faked or
would you say most i don't think we went
ever i don't think so that's a bummer
that's what about the russians i don't
they didn't go to the moon
i don't think we got through the van
allen belt i don't think we have the
technology yet to do it but you don't
think anybody's been to the moon i don't
think so [ __ ] find the hubble telescope
taking pictures of the rover and
footprints on the moon oh boy norton you
may have stepped in it you may have
stepped in some real evidence
that this [ __ ] is making maybe i'm
incorrect
thank you tom
earthbase yeah i'm saying i don't know
if it's earth-based or not earth-based
photos finding the flag the footprints
and the rovers on the moon oh okay there
are a thousand times too small to be
seen for an earth-based telescope so
maybe it's just a uh that's convenient
you can see galaxies far away but you
can't see the the footprints well the
difference is you're seeing
you can see the galaxies yeah because
it's light whereas a footprint is a
little dark mark on a uh the rovers are
all still there well galaxies are also
galaxies are huge i mean we can zoom in
on
tiny little things on mars yeah but when
you see a galaxy you're seeing a billion
stars that looks like one point of light
like you're seeing something that is is
is say 50 or a thousand light years wide
as a pinpoint of light
like that's all you're seeing you're not
seeing individual stuff in the galaxy
but you understand we have the
technology on earth to take pictures of
mars
tiny little detail on the surface of
mars
we can't get those footprints so we
should be able to see the the rover that
landed on the moon well the details we
take on mars you're right but i think
those are from the rover that's actually
there pre-pre that and i'm guessing
that's from something that was orbiting
the moon probably not from earth so then
there must be something
i don't know okay so he's saying well if
it's orbiting the moon well i can't take
pictures of footprints yeah are there no
photos of the footprints from spa maybe
i'm wrong i mean it's but that's wild i
mean that should that would just debunk
everything should be like look here's a
picture we took there's the rover
sitting there on moon it would it
wouldn't debunk anything to me um the
rover they should be able to see but the
footprints wouldn't debunk it i was just
in the rover
are there no photos of the rover or the
flag
or the flag let's see that flag yeah
maybe they're too small i don't i mean i
don't have an answer see that doesn't
make any sense to me well there's no
light source from it either like those
things that are taken when you talk
about things in space they're light
sources they're all they're taking with
like under ultraviolet ultraviolet light
or they're seen as light i mean there
was light on the astronauts when they
landed on the moon you could obviously
because from the photos lit yes from
there so
that means that light does shine on that
place of the moon so not the dark side
of the moon no light shining again i'm
not a scientist light shining on it
might give a different uh ability to be
photographed than actually it emitting
light and giving off a source source of
light a land rover is a pretty big
vehicle
how big is it yeah it's it's a frame of
a jeep
nice yep i don't know why can't now is
that can they not find photos of it or
no of what the rover the rover from
earth i don't know are you looking for
footprints but by the way the a universe
is way bigger than a jeep yeah i mean
that it's compare i know what you have a
jeep yeah you couldn't fit a universe in
there no sam you could what i'm saying
is with mars you can take detailed
photos from earth
on mars but you can't take more detailed
i i what's what detailed photos of mars
are people taking from earth
whatever you could even other planets
jupiter you can get what are they
looking at their travis in 2011
this was these are photos taken from
nasa's lunar reconnaissance orbiter
uh captured the sharpest images ever
taken from space of the apollo 12 14 and
17 landing sites okay so you can't take
the photo i defeat i was wrong um
let me open them up a little bit
yeah and if they're lying about it why
wouldn't they why wouldn't they fake
clear photos
if they could fake the moon landing why
wouldn't they fake better photos that's
a tremendous question
how are they taking that bat of photos i
don't think it's a bad photo i just
think that something in 2014 that's the
best photo we can get of the moon from
space maybe yeah
from an orbiter yeah geyser what do they
got an iphone yeah maybe from space it's
a tougher photo to take yeah they didn't
send it it's wild how detailed these
photos can get from anywhere but all
this they're this blurry well i haven't
seen anything that's the size of a jeep
on mars
i haven't seen yeah what are some
earth-based photos of mars
galaxies are a bad example just because
space is black they're light and they're
also huge and you're also seeing
something that's you know a thousand
light years wide as a pinpoint of light
right that's how our tech our our
telescopes are good but you're seeing
something that a billion think a lot of
giant things bigger than our sun okay
you're seeing is one point of light
that's the best earth-based view of mars
and it's the whole planet it's the least
it's the least
it's a terribly okay undetailed photo
but is that are there
is do you have the capability of taking
photos
of the moon from space
yeah yes so why can't we get a detailed
photo of the land rover sitting on them
my guess is that they haven't spent a
lot of time doing it like for what like
whenever they take photos
whenever they take photos from space
they usually aim a camera somewhere and
they have a reason to do it and there's
a limited amount of time because
everything's moving so if somebody said
why don't we take photos from space
of the moon landing site somebody would
go why
like for what
why we did it like like i don't know
whether you do that there's no purposes
like well people are saying nobody
landed here let's just show them that
look there's the [ __ ] we put there but
maybe scientists don't that's a good
point maybe they're not looking at it
like let's get a very small
segment of people who won't believe it
anyway
to shut up and we can actually use this
for scientific purposes that we need why
not just get a filmmaker to take a
picture of the rover
if a filmmaker did it and if it's there
and we have good technology what just
have somebody take a picture of it i'm
guessing that the craters look
small like we look look at how small
those little details photos are taking
but they're not small they're actual
craters they're huge that are large yeah
they look small but they're not canyons
yeah they're big yeah that makes sense i
mean from space you can zoom in on
google maps into tiny little from way up
in space zoom in you can't take a photo
of a land rover on mars
i guess those are the best photos they
have but if they haven't tried it in 10
years
if that's the most detailed photos they
have is 10 years ago plus if google maps
were that good they wouldn't need those
cars driving around neighborhoods with
the cameras on the top to the excellent
point thank you
thank you
yeah thank you
and you can get a certain amount of
detail from google like when you zoom in
from google uh
satellites you can you can get i know
are are the things are google satellites
closer
than the ones how far was that thing
that took those photos i don't know any
of the answer to that well i mean yeah
google satellites are right above us
right how far was that taken from was
that taken from something that was the
same distance
probably not
this is where you need uh dr tyson
or anything troy doesn't think so i'd
rather get dr steve
let's see 40 years later flags remain on
the moon how do they know
in parentheses it says we guess yeah
probably no it says flags remain in
quotes
[Laughter]
i don't know how far away it was 100
meters
okay let's see what tom and uh let's see
what tom in connecticut has to say
because this is a wild ass phone call
description uh what's up tom troy from
the other room
hey i just want to say that uh all of
the nasa stuff is fake because my
grandmother is christa mcauliffe
from the challenger mike drop
[ __ ] whoa
so she lived
yes that's right i said is oh my god oh
no
my god jesus and i'm going to tell you
tom i may not know your last name i'm
going to take your word for it
i was in the room so i wasn't sworn to
secrecy i'm allowed to say it
we finally found one thank you thank you
for your service thank you yeah thanks
tom
not sworn to secrecy got the answer
it's amazing that we have not don't have
the technology to get to the moon but we
can send a satellite into space to do
the radio show
yeah and we can also have things like
the space station and tourists now going
up
just a real real right above us yeah
well they're floating i mean
not to the moon though no
nobody's been on the moon no and the
soviets would never have called here's
the beautiful thing about the russians
they would never have called us out on
it neither were the chinese
well they cooperate the russia and the
chinese would never have called us out
on the lie why didn't they do that call
it out on the line yeah why didn't i
maybe they don't know
technology why didn't but why wouldn't
it even now why wouldn't the russians be
like [ __ ] yeah maybe that's who did
american moon on uh youtube the russians
that's that's
what it sounded like and they pretend to
go to moon i'm telling you this is a
great documentary you should watch it
sometimes three and a half hours of
course it is
of course it is
well you can make it five minutes
they clearly go into explaining what
it's like there's a lot to digest you
think there's a lot of circle talk
remember when i told you that there's
all this like stuff on the internet that
makes people crazy and convinces them
that they're right never mind uh so
very positive comments are they okay you
know what it's hard to have three and a
half hours but i try to watch this stuff
because i like to be informed watch it
jim so watch it watch it i'll watch it
piecemeal i did watch the one ufo
documentary that you you told me about
it and i did and i watched the other one
that came out yeah um and they they all
it was amazing up until they went into
the the african kids because i don't
want to [ __ ] hear what a bunch of
children said that that is a pretty wild
scenario all these big times yes
absolutely yeah but i was just too long
on it like you don't think that's worth
examining it is but not it did it lost
me because i have much more interest in
what pilots say and what and possible
photos and videos than what children say
and that was at the end of the
documentary it was too long it was long
it was that part the fact that six kids
all saw the same thing come on pretty
wild yeah the mcmartin preschool the
whole [ __ ] school said they were
molested and it turns out they weren't
like mine i don't kids
minds i don't are not to me as
trustworthy as
adult minds like and pilots i would put
more stock in i could listen to a pilot
tell the same story
as another pilot over and over again i
would put more on that
i'd just much rather hear them saying it
you put higher stock in that yeah
but the kids you could have but i just
thought they spent too much time on it
and they wasted what could have been a
lot of valuable
time
uh
patrick in new jersey
uh hey guys um
i think it's interesting that troy
thinks that we can't make it to the moon
but we can launch a satellite that can
look at the edge of the universe where
the light is taking literally millions
of years to get here
and he uses that as a justification the
hubble space telescope isn't looking at
light that you see
in the moment it's looking at light
that's millions of years old we have
that technology yeah and we also have
the technology to put the james webb
telescope that doesn't orbit earth
that orbits um
between the moon and sun right miles
away yeah that's the one i asked that
astronaut about the james webb i didn't
know the name of it but that was the one
i asked it's in in not deep space but
deeper space than than hubble yeah and
um
how did he handle the question
he had no idea his grace
the gravitation of the sun and the moon
sorry the sun and earth at a million
miles away yeah and they'll probably get
amazing
amazing is it up there now i think
they're still running tests yeah right
for a few months
yeah it's in position now and they
completely unfolded all of the
um
the mirrors that go along with the
telescope uh and it's it's in there
ready to go they're just finalizing all
the fine-tuning all the the mirrors and
sensors um and then the other thing i
wanted to say is if you go to space.com
which i'm sure is a [ __ ] conspiracy
site uh you go and you can actually see
the apollo 11 moon landing site
ah how far away is the james webb
telescope do you know
not not not specifically but i think
it's either a million miles or a million
kilometers away oh yeah i'm wondering
how long it takes like if there's a
repair to be done like on the hubble
they can fly guys up what how would they
repair this james webb would they have
to send just a machine
really you can't
yeah it's that far away i think it took
like six months to get there
uh we looked it up travis i'm curious
you don't know how far away it is 237
yeah 30
can they send
is there any type of like a an automated
ship they can send to do repairs on that
if they had to there's got to be a way
to fix something well if if they need to
do repairs they can just go to the sound
stage that it's really on
thank you
oh thank you patrick
what does this say
uh location in orbit it's this is the uh
james webb telescope its actual position
varies between about 250 000 kilometers
832 000 kilometers which is about 517
000 miles from l2 as it orbits
that's weird yeah um
keeping it out of both earth and moon's
orbit that's five
and the hubble is 550 kilometers so this
is way further l2 is shorthand
for the second is it a gravitational
thing between the moon and or earth and
sun a wonderful accident of gravity and
orbital mechanics how do they know
i don't know the gravity from the sun
and the earth balance the orbital motion
of a satellite it's just it's like a
weird place between two or uh between
two points of gravity
lies a million miles from earth oh wow
he's right million miles
but in the opposite direction of the sun
allegedly wait
thank you oh it's not towards the sun
no it's the opposite direction again oh
i thought it was a million miles towards
the sun i was wondering wouldn't that
[ __ ] up the pictures all that bright
light
allegedly
i tell you if this is if we if all this
is true what troy's saying that show
third rock from the sun makes no sense
you know what with the earth moon and
sun behind it a spacecraft can get a
clear okay that makes sense i thought it
was between the earth and sun and i'm
like i think the light from the sun i
mean if the empire state building [ __ ]
up a photo because of the light
does the sun not do it that's true it's
a million miles in the space with all of
us behind it okay perfect true
can they can they can they do repairs on
if they had to or no
if it's broke it's broke
what is this called
james webb come on travis get with it
uh
let's go to charles in
chicago man is
is travis the most james webb is not
designed to be serviced or repaired wow
you might be the most heavy-fingered
typer that i have ever encountered it's
got strong hands baby
i thought we were landing on the
moon it is out of reach
just out of reach that is a [ __ ] you
just got to hope you're trying to
million dollars what if something
doesn't open up right you you can't have
there must be
some checks and balances on it that can
kind of self-repair a little bit there
has to be to adjust
holy [ __ ] imagine if it broke right when
it went up there ah man [ __ ] or if a
little piece of moon debris or space
debris hit it knocked it oh nerds dude
there's [ __ ] space debris all over
the place little rocks yeah
things the size of this microphone
flying around oh yeah oh you bet there
is
charles in chicago hello
yeah how about we uh just look at the
other countries that have made moon
landings
we keep concentrating on the us but
there are several other countries that
have made moon lands i didn't know if
there were or not i honestly didn't know
okay well how about if there's a rover
from china on the moon
well
if we faked it because we can't get
there
and then china was like hey we went to
the moon
wouldn't america have been like no
that's horseshit to china didn't go to
china say like they never went we just
went there we checked
yeah and if they yeah and if china did
go to the moon they'd be like guys this
is crazy not only did we go to the moon
there's not [ __ ] up there do you know
what dicks they could make us look like
oh no rover no flag no footprint i mean
it is untouched
and there's energy and there's
international cooperation between i mean
i think russia just ended it between the
soviets and even in bad times we kind of
always cooperated um but yeah that's a
great point how many countries have gone
to the moon i didn't think to that point
there is
astronauts on them there are
other countries that put astronauts on
the moon no no or roe versus whatever
i'm not saying you can't send a rover
but then why wouldn't they point out the
fact that we haven't
seven countries yeah where's seven
countries you think they'd be like oh
look here's the american rover we found
it for what like for them
you and i having this fun chat
scientists don't need to do that like
they don't descript her scientists don't
go like hey let's prove to people that
we're here like they just for what yeah
it just that doesn't make sense to me i
don't know why just somebody just
doesn't from earth take a picture of the
moon where we landed we didn't land on
the dark side of the moon you don't
think luxembourg when they went would
have said hey
there's no flag here then where's the
just take a [ __ ] picture let me see
it
so wait countries which have landed or
orbited the moon by number of missions
us 30
us ssr russia 23
china seven so you think there are
thirty
sixty between these three
1990 it ends in 1990 so by then you
think there are 60
missions with
different countries
different um astronauts
and different
uh different control rooms full of
people
all of who are silent and none who are
tattling on each other sworn but again
sworn no astronauts just america is the
only one that's possessed
but but again the other one is
interesting the other ones not knowing
that this was faked but like if if
russia's gone so many times just send an
astronaut or a cosmonaut to the moon
busy maybe they figure there's nothing
to be gained by it maybe they can't get
through the van allen belt
do you think we're secretly in cahoots
with russia and china passed possibly
very possibly right
would you be surprised if we were yes
i i i would be
as a matter of fact i'd be 100 surprised
if we were yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting sure
we have to break if we have mark norman
coming we don't want to be late for mark